the historic Juniper Hill Inn sits on a
Hilltop above the quaint Village of
Windsor Vermont built in 1902 the
country mansioned both 28 luxurious
bedrooms
and two grand dining rooms it is filled
with original works of art and antiques
all museum quality antiques dealer
Robert Dean II and his boyfriend Ari
Nikki bought the business six years ago
I've always thought that you should live
with nice things if you can afford them
oh this looks good there Robert I
thought you'd like it the guests that we
don't want here are people who don't
have a lot of money that it may look the
part but despite Robert's dreams of an
elite country estate the hotel is barely
functioning Robert Dean has no hotel or
no restaurant experience the prices may
be a little bit high for locals 350
tonight minimum so that's 700 the lack
of communication is very frustrating
where are you
I know the customers see that every day
too because at this point I can't even
get in my room with bookings at an
all-time low the hotel is in serious
financial trouble
but that doesn't stop Robert from living
a Millionaire's dream Robert believes
this place is his playground
in the playground for his friends he's
gotta have a lot of clothes made
that again
he comps all their meals and rooms but
we never get tips they're having a hard
time paying me because they give away
all of their money and food to their
friends showing off using this as their
private castle with hardly any paying
guests it's no wonder that this Inn is
in the red yes we are losing money more
or less like 200 000 a year
this is going to be closed and it's
that's very very sad Gordon is going to
come into this place and say this place
is [__]
if I don't stop this business from
bleeding money it's doomed
I'd love to own an end in a setting like
this if you get it right you'd make an
absolute Fortune before I get to Juniper
Hill I want to find out what the town's
folk think of their local Inn
how are you very well and yourself yeah
I think I've been driving all morning um
Juniper help in you're gonna love it
it's beautiful and reputation it tends
to be a little on the high end for our
area okay but I would love to have a
place to go to locally do they not
invite locals up there I feel um that
I'd be interrupting I feel like I'd be
intruding everybody
what a shame thank you so much have a
great day thank you very much indeed
thank you
here we are Juniper Hill Inn now who in
the hell would bring an RV all the way
up here and not stay in that stunning
hotel look at it
my God that's beautiful wow okay around
to the front door
[Music]
I can't believe they can clear the snow
for guests to come in
[Music]
you're kidding me
it's locked that's not very welcoming
[Music]
well if you have a big mansion then
guests can't arrive through the front
[__] door
Jesus who wants to enter through the
back door
Mr Ramsey is here I need you to do room
one right away
[Music]
were you over there I was at the front
door yes okay this is actually our
entrance and in the winter because of
snow ready we have to keep that locked
and otherwise the snow load comes off
and kills people kills people yeah it
can have you killed anyone so no
where's all this stuff from
um
an aftermath of a antiques Fair yeah
this looks like it could be a beautiful
room but you can't tell because it's
stuck with so much clutter that's the
reception desk no my dad said what is
that that is our bar right now you are
kidding me this is the bar yes with what
the martinis martinis yeah God bless him
uh made of pigs Pig Martini well we have
three rescue potbellied pigs you have
three pigs here right what is that for
were you born with this in your mouth
yeah I don't know where's honestly I
actually know that was a gift from a
giant so yeah Robert obviously loves to
show off all his expensive antiques but
as a guest I don't feel comfortable I
feel like I'm in the museum
this is the main formal dining room this
big chair here is four for one uh just
kind of we're known as a romantic
destination and uh just out of Interest
well we would move the table move it in
for me please yes
wow so you've got a sofa on the table we
thought it was kind of nice to have like
a cozy banquet
oh
three U.S presidents have dined here oh
really which ones uh Teddy Roosevelt
Calvin Coolidge Teddy Roosevelt died in
here wow I wanted to try to give him a
little bit of sense of the history of
juniper Hill wow okay so that's the
dining room well we have two dining
rooms oh God you must be busy with two
dining rooms well I wish we were busy
let's see how we have spurts of being
incredibly busy right uh where we lack
is all the other times ready yeah
this place looks like a Millionaire's
Mansion not a struggling business I've
got to scratch beneath the surface this
place per week is telling how much we're
lucky if we're doing you know 15 000 a
month what does it cost to keep the
place open
30. ready yep
so you're losing
two hundred thousand dollars a year it's
been a nightmare we maintained our room
rates thinking that the economy wouldn't
be this long a haul we've all
experienced those kind of devotees and
myself including but you you navigate
your way out of that recession
unfortunately my partner lost his job we
expected him to have his job for a
little longer he must have gained a
substantial payoff or retirement it's
all been put into this how much
over a million dollars a million dollars
into this already Yes and does he have
an active role in the business he tries
to maintain the accounting and he helps
just about with everything we're in
trouble
you'd never guess from the look of this
place it's more like Buckingham Palace
and Skid Row do you know what um Robert
honestly I had to go straight to my room
if you would okay all right wow this
goes on it does it's the largest
culinary Revival Mansion in New England
more paintings and you're in the Maxwell
at Art Suite which is the original uh
okay wow beautiful room
and uh
I mean this is uh
it's a beautiful room but what is that
smell
seriously it's it does smell
yeah
[Music]
it smells terrific oh my God it smells
like sewage
[Music]
I'm at Vermont Juniper hillian and I've
just met his owner Robert Dean II who's
filled his hotel with expensive art and
antiques were you born with this in your
mouth but he can't fill his rooms and
his business is struggling you're losing
200 000 a year it's been a nightmare and
no wonder because although the room he's
put me in looks nice beautiful room it
has one major drawback what is that
smell it smells like raw sewage we had a
plumbing issue and it's like someone's
shot under the bed and
um how much this room goes for
350 a night 350 a night for room that
smells of [__] well you're kidding me we
haven't rented it though bloody hell
it's been out of use for
um four months four months yeah oh come
on it has been this is crazy it is crazy
it just makes sense I've got to get out
of here is there another room yes I have
room too bloody hell I didn't realize
350 to be caked in [__]
wow it's gorgeous and this one doesn't
smell like crap I'm gonna quickly uh
unpack and then I would uh I would like
to have a um a quick bite of lunch okay
I'll tell I'll notify this what time is
the restaurant close for lunch well we
actually don't serve lunch normally
but we're happy to prepare you something
is that a joke we serve breakfast stop
stop stop stop stop you don't actually
serve lunch no the restaurant's close
for lunch yes if someone requests lunch
we'll make lunch for them but could you
uh prepare lunch for me uh yes I can
I'll tell the chef please okay uh thank
you yes
not open for lunch Gordon is gonna want
lunch huh Gordon wants lunch
what am I supposed to do with that
information
[Music]
that was a welcome breath of fresh air
on the back
of the max gusting smoke
room I can't believe it and that are
gorgeous and yet how could you have a
room that
has been smelling for months that bad
and then he sticks me in it
what a muppet
despite the Hideous smell in that first
guest room
I've still worked up quite an appetite
hello
Hi how are you Barbara Barbara how
glamorous are you I'm nice to see you I
have a mad crush on as he knows I'm a
cougar how old are you now
last week I turned 70. you're kidding me
watch out Joan Collins I'm telling you
now bloody hell
Baba what's wrong with this place well
in a nutshell don't get any people like
pulling teeth to get my paycheck
you don't get paid it takes forever to
get my paycheck and when I do it's
usually something's left out but hold on
a minute you you don't get paid and when
you do it not on time we spoke you're
supposed to get paid every two weeks so
what do you earn a fortnight I made 6
000 this year
six thousand dollars a year
it's ridiculous you know you got to have
the money flowing and it's almost come
to a standstill at this point my last
paycheck was 48 dollars I'm
Robert's obviously got enough money to
fill the guest rooms with Fine Art and
antique furniture but it doesn't pay his
staff
and I'm starving what would you
recommend for the crab cakes with a
little salad so this is the dinner menu
okay because we're not open for lunch
and the lamb sounds great as well you
want the lamb yeah all right darling is
this a prefix menu or yeah because
there's no prices on here what sort of
Russian doesn't have prices on the menu
It's like a club for millionaires where
if you have to ask you can't afford it
I've got a supplement of 15 for my lamb
how much is enough charge for the lamb
is Robert nearby
[Music]
how much is it for three quarters fifty
nine dollars fifty nine dollars so if we
had the lab it would be 74. people are
horrified at the price of the food this
is why a lot of people think that
Juniper Hill is snobbish when we
typically take a reservation we will
tell people it's a three-course meal but
that's for the residents I'm talking
about a local coming in here we're
reservation only though so nobody walks
in we don't have to walk in how can you
expect to appeal to the locals
um we haven't identified the appropriate
people to come here or what do you mean
appropriate people people who can afford
59 for three courses appropriate people
what a snob where does he think he is
the Ritz and where's your table which
one's your table
well most of the time I eat in our RV
our motor coach say that again oh we
have a motor coach to the side right and
where'd it come from is it yours you
rent it yeah it's ours I mean we owe on
it but we bought it and we bought it
yeah how much was that over a hundred
thousand dollars
a hundred thousand dollars
you're three years away from 50 you
should not be living in an RV
we don't live in an RV
um it is a motor coach which is the
higher end version of an RV it is that
psychological break for us and it gives
me a place to relax and kind of unwind I
actually love it I could live here the
rest of my life to be honest with you
it's quiet it's clean I suppose if this
place doesn't get fixed then you might
be in there full time yeah
I've just sat down for lunch at the
Juniper hilly hello and already I found
out the staff aren't paid on time like
pulling teeth to get my paycheck and the
owners live in a camper outside
how much was that over a hundred
thousand dollars this place is baffling
I hope the food makes more sense
excess wow
where are the crab cakes
oh that's there underneath there are
they mini crab cakes are we uh the chef
has deciding that those are the size
that he needs to serve
I mean that tastes Dreadful that thing
tastes sort of washy and soapy
for that
he's as cheap with his crab cakes as he
is with his staff
now for the Lamb with Robert's
ridiculous 15 extra charge
it's um a rack of lamb encrusted in
macadamia nuts fresh herbs and a little
bit of Dijon mustard it's served with a
honey vinegar reduction
I even cook properly
almost didn't take that off
I always get nervous when you see white
fat like that
on the side of the chop
[Music]
to your liking
I mean
it's pretty raw in the center you like
the flavor of it though the Honey Garden
way too sweet
I I'm not satisfied with the quality of
the foods coming out of the kitchen I
believe our Chef has a learning curve he
needs to be thank you
we just lost our other Chef why why did
the chef leave
I'm supposed to tell you the truth right
the truth is all I want to know why did
the chef leave well her paycheck
she put all everything on her charge
cards and and she just figured she
wasn't paid back for what she Chef
bought produce she did she did
everything she was the best chef ever oh
that's Dreadful
starving the peanut butter chocolate
decadence I could do with some of that
pick me up please thank you
God a chef that left because she had to
buy produce on her own credit card I
mean this guy's priorities are upside
down
a bit like this in okay are you ready
this he said he doesn't care for the
sweetness there's fat around it he
didn't care for the flavor of the
honeygar
thank you
[Music]
wow thank you very much um did you cut
it in half because it looks like
something and where's the other half
gone uh goes to the another person oh no
I want my half
74 dollars
this place is insane
listen half my dessert's missing if you
think I'm spending 74 dollars for
dessert
that is half cocked
[Music]
it's actually quite nice there is hope
I'm sorry I'm trying to say that that is
not a dessert that he made Barbara made
it no somebody else makes desserts it's
ordered like store-bought like through
one of our purveyors what
where's the chef he's in the kitchen can
you get him out please what
how you doing Chef Julian in my opinion
is not living up to his potential as a
chef he will try to cut corners and I
think Gordon needs to know these things
I've just spent 74 dollars for three
plates of absolute dire dated [__] food
[Music]
cakes yes sir you can't put two little
half testicle size [__] crab cakes
that came from a can there's bigger
[__] cakes chef at the [__] canopy
party my lamb was cold in the middle the
fat was white it was almost like a
mouthful of sugar the best tasting dish
for me was the [__] chocolate peanut
thing that I got served half a portion
that's not even made [__] in-house
what is this there's no Synergy here
there is honestly a lack of
communication often sometimes when I'm
in the middle of doing breakfast service
for the 10 people that we randomly get I
get five texts from him asking me a
question
so why are you texting him if you have a
question I should maybe leave the RV and
come out and talk to him show me those
texts are you nitpicking are you trying
to control him are you no I'm trying to
make sure I I'm I haven't been sleeping
very well to be honest with you and uh
I've had I've been beaten down
I'll take responsibility for everything
that happens in the kitchen you don't
you do nice you own it yeah he's
edible
a thousand dollars four taxes 400.
400 a week to be the head chef in a
luxury hotel that's insane I mean you're
barely surviving I'm I'm I don't know
that I'm even barely surviving if you're
not happy with your work environment you
should leave are you taking the piss or
is this just an abuse for you what are
you doing to these people
so they're livelihoods this is your
responsibility
[Music]
Rob's World and you're in an RV a
hundred grand
everybody is disgusted that you live in
that thing they really are because it
costs so much money and they can't get
their paycheck on time
well that is not the that is part of the
issue we are surrounded by wealth and
reminded of poverty at the same time
because of that RV it's a symbol to me
that RV is a simple
and it's a symbol that you're separating
yourself from everybody else I'd be very
careful about coming down on me too hard
I'm telling you exactly how I feel and
how that makes the people that I work
with feel let me tell you how I feel
when you're in your [__] kitchen all
day long and you're on the goddamn
internet instead of actually trying to
perfect a menu and get a menu how long
did I ask for you to make a menu of your
own and if I'm on the computer usually
as I'm trying to research menus research
ingredients give me a break I've given
you plenty of rings I work very long
days and I haven't been paid in three
weeks there's only been one paycheck
that I got on time almost the entire
staff is ready to walk out because they
are tired of not getting paid
anything to say
no we we do things oh please
[Music]
it's my first day at Vermont Juniper
hillion and the battle between the chef
and the owner and be very careful about
coming down on me too hard it has turned
what should be a Charming country in
into a war zone I'm telling you exactly
how I feel I work very long days yeah
and I haven't been paid in three weeks
there's only been one paycheck that I
got on time almost the entire staff is
ready to walk out because they are tired
of not getting paid
anything to say
no
we're tired and half the team is broke
I'm beyond angry I'm beyond pissed off
well I just got the new [__] ripped
to me
Gordon says that I live in a fantasy
world and that uh
I live in a million dollar RV while our
our employees can't pay their bills and
all of this kind of stuff because we
don't pay them on time and they're all
complaining that they haven't gotten
their paychecks this time either oh they
haven't
and he said that everything is all about
me
I can't believe what a mess this place
is I've got to get off this hill for a
bit
that's someone I need to see
hello is that Lida it's Gordon Ramsay
I've got some questions about Robert and
Jennifer Hill would you mind if I pop
over for five minutes please
great I'll see you then thanks
[Music]
I think the old Chef that quits will be
able to give me some insight into what's
wrong with juniper Hill
good to see you good to see you come on
in
give you a little insight to what it was
like actually working there I have to
say it was a very interesting five years
uh things were going very very well and
then all of a sudden two years into it
they stop answering the phone
Robert I think thought he was too
important to answer the phone or he was
too busy doing other things it's a
preoccupied and distracted very very
preoccupied and distracted and not
focused at all on maintaining his own
business wow I was getting cut out of a
living when they did all this stuff I
used to earn 40 50 000 in one restaurant
and now I'm down to earning uh 15. well
you paid on time
um not very often
um did you ever use your own money to
buy things all the time
and then I would have to demand to be
paid back or we weren't going to open
for dinner it's insane Barbara has been
shorted checks a lot she's barely
earning 100 a week yeah and he won't
pair and then if he had a private party
with all his friends he didn't tip them
you're kidding me no
it's just this stuff I mean that's where
I do that you can't do that no you just
can't treat people like that now he's a
confirmed snob and he thinks he's above
the town he thinks he's untouchable
I'm here to make this place work um the
first thing I'm going to do is burst his
bubble I'd like to be a fly on that wall
but would you come back and walk through
the doors to have a look at it at the
end of the week and just
come back for dinner no no just won't go
or no I'm not even interested in getting
it I just fear getting it in one more
battle with Aria or Robert after five
years yeah do you think I've got a
chance of saving it the problem is now
is nobody will work there you know I'm
there to get this place turned around
um those staff deserve a better future
they do you know I feel terrible for
them um listen thank you you're very
welcome um appreciate your time enjoyed
it thanks nice to meet you too bye-bye
bye-bye
how sad is that after five years of her
life dedicated
to the Juniper Hill you know she won't
even step foot in the door just see them
the old Chef left because she couldn't
stand it and the current Chef looks like
he's ready to walk too I wonder if
everyone here is feeling the same
frustration
what's wrong with the place what's wrong
with this place we're lacking uh
paychecks on time paycheck you don't get
paid on time either no
basic supplies we don't even have I mean
Noel purchased guest checks for us today
so that we've been using scrap pieces of
paper
[Music]
first name is I'm Ryan Keith Ryan Keith
and what'd you do I'm the estate manager
here I do all the maintenance on the
house I've done everything here though
that's why he likes me to spread out my
talents to try and help anybody wherever
they need help how's morale
not good
I personally haven't been paid since the
6th of January here it is the first of
February
that's nearly a month you pay the
employees before paying your bills when
they've done the work that's their
livelihood I'm amazed you're still here
working as hard as you are because staff
never needs to be treated like this let
me tell you
it's always as if what you're saying to
him doesn't get through because he sees
you as not an equal
he treats me like that and that really
bothers me because I feel like I've
contributed a lot it's actually pretty
degrading I see
[Music]
I'm shocked with what I'm finding at the
Juniper Helene owner Robert wants the
killing Chef how long did I ask for you
to make a menu of your own and the rest
of the staff want to kill Robert how's
morale not good estate manager Ryan has
told me about some of the problems but
now he wants to show me if you want to
see the root of the problem that's kind
of the best one it's the basement yes
please Jesus what's in there everything
oh really it's the majority of it is
personal items you know even the shelves
are all lined let's see how look at this
place
oh my God
look at this stuff
stereos wine racks quilts chairs tables
copper pans more chairs over there look
at these Robert Prides himself in having
to have the very best of everything
Christ is enough in here to open three
restaurants is all this stuff still
brand new most of it is brand new little
with thousands of dollars Robert's got
so much stuff he could furnish a dozen
houses but he doesn't pay his staff it's
crazy where we go raise yourself we're
going up to the office
you're kidding me oh no come on this is
the office this is the office you're
kidding me not at all I wanted you to
Jesus Christ scares me half to death oh
my gosh this is insane it would only
take a day or two to sort out this
horde's heaven but Rob has left it in
chaos no wonder he spends all day hiding
in his RV
this guy has lost the plots this is
disturbing
please tell me there's no more
yes there's more this is where the pigs
are kept
at least they look happy hey pigs who
live a life of luxury while everyone
around them suffers so strangely
familiar bloody hell so the owners live
out the pigs live in there's more so
check out the storage units storage
units
no oh my God
this one's all personal items oh Jesus
I mean I swear to God it's like a
special edition of Hoarders
I mean honestly wow
I'm in shock you know that
and this one
all of this entire storage unit is full
of chairs
oh my God
look at this stuff honestly I mean they
must be packed with thousands of dollars
worth of hundreds of thousands of
dollars how much stuff does one need
[Music]
flirty how
I can't believe how much stuff Robert
has bought he must have spent a fortune
I've got to meet Robert's partner Ari
and find out why he's financing all this
it's a pleasure please
um my God so how much money have you put
into this business personally more or
lesser over a million dollars a million
dollars and how much have you seen back
nothing
it was on my uh separates packages my
income that I when I was working and
then my retirement plans rapid savings
are in artwork and antiques I have
supporting this in with my my savings
clearly this is a beautiful place but
putting your entire life savings into a
sinking ship is insane and with Robert
at the helm treating his staff so poorly
I don't see things getting any better
Robert is in a fantasy world and I've
been struggling all day to get through
to him
this place it's Dreamland a playground
for your boyfriend Robert
your biggest problem
is not Juniper Hill your biggest problem
is [__] Robert
I'm at Vermont's Juniper Hill Inn and
I've just had a difficult conversation
with Robert's partner Ari who seems
strangely unconcerned about how bad
things really are here how much money
have you put into this business
personally over million dollars
how much have you seen back nothing
tried to make him see who's to blame for
the problems your biggest problem is
[__] Robert
dinner time is approaching word has
spread about me being at the inn and the
place is bustling hello there nice to
see you I'm learning a lot about why the
Inn is struggling by watching Robert and
Ari deal with the new influx of guests
anyone with any wrestler experience
would stagger the seating of guests but
as if they're just welcoming people to a
dinner party at a private house hello
there how are you Robert and Ari see
everyone at once yeah at the corner May
pretend you're back in 1902 it's meant
to be a relaxed evening and that's the
recipe for disaster for Chef Julian and
the wait staff
by making a change on 21. write it down
don't tell me just write it down it's an
order
are you guys kidding me with all these
orders who said everybody at once like
this we don't know about pacing
who's writing the tickets Jimmy now in
table four table five some of them have
names on them some of them do not who
wrote that ticket there's not even a
table number in there table four they
just got their lobster where's table 23
they've got I need one person at a time
I need less talking in the kitchen
tables 23 has got no window eight people
ask me for something with Julian haven't
been slammed by the owner's Dreadful
seating Ari isn't helping the strained
atmosphere with an awkward art lesson
and then like this this is from 1800 and
it was painted for opera house because
you know what it is
what is it come on everybody has to know
what that is it's a hand about going
across the ABS with the white elephants
everybody should know that
laughs
[Music]
on the other side of the house Robert's
also busy giving a lecture this is one
of the original signs to the house
there's a lot of history here Teddy
Roosevelt actually was best friends with
the man or a very good friend with the
man who actually built the house Maxwell
ever
did you always get this backed up I mean
yes yeah when I have
four seating Robert has groups of his
friends come in sitting him at once okay
so you're waiting for your starters
though yes okay well let me uh check on
those for you okay yeah
Robert yes this ticket system is
bollocks
handwritten tickets no time on there no
proper dates no coordination
who trains the front of house team who's
in charge of the restaurant who is there
I would be the host and then you'll be
the host yes the chef takes over the
kitchen this place is such a mess
clearly Robert has no idea how to run a
hotel yeah
drinks because they lose we lost 30
something drinks oh my gosh
Robert who lost 30 drinks at least I
often find drinks not written down or
just a lack of follow-through and it's a
big problem when we're trying to make
money there's no communication between
the bar and the dining room so people
get served drinks but no one remembers
the charge for them oh we're losing big
money no kidding and they're losing
their checks and I'm going crazy trying
to figure out a system they have hardly
any guess and don't charge the ones they
do have no wonder this place is in the
red how does that happen if they're
supposed to ride the drinks down and
then apply them to a table and a room
and then they go into the computer
the ticket system is bogus and as I
feared seating everyone at once is
already causing problems for the staff
and the guests
it's not very warm
with guests now suffering and the
kitchen falling apart from robbers
ill-managed seating come on I have to
step in
um just to just stop there
you have to be [__] kidding me this
Goose liver is burnt to a cinder stop
Julian yes come around buddy I know
we're in this [__] and we're busy food's
dying in the window
a foie gras salad
I mean honestly
it's like a piece of [__] beef jerky
where's Ari get me Ari urgently
I mean honestly come on guys
hello I stopped that I've just said no
what is that what is that foie gras
that is it's not funny guys oh that is
not funny I mean I know we're in the
ship but does anyone have any standards
here yes
well can I see them
can I say something don't want to
because right now I just want to get out
of here
I can only be as good as I am with the
tools that I have I'm embarrassed and I
know that I can do better I know the
staff can do better first off no more
[__] tickets in the kitchen give him
10 minutes to catch up okay all right
I'm Robert is it possible for the first
time put the phone away get your jacket
off and [__] dig deep a little bit
yeah please yeah somebody I'm concerned
that food is in the window and it's just
dying entrees on table six are in the
Wind on trade send them they should be
sat here how am I supposed to do
everything baby are you with me are you
an owner I'm with you are you an
entrepreneur I keep trying to you know
you can talk to him he's your [__]
Chef well when I try to communicate with
us yeah yeah yeah no no no no no no I
can't do it no he doesn't [__] find
your balls and tell him you need to talk
about my balls do I want him to walk out
he's not gonna walk out if you
communicate with him talk to him there
well I have been trying to so when he
finishes it send the [__] food which
is always a third dish not ready or a
fourth dish well it must be one or two
moves behind but unless you [__] ask
how he's supposed to [__] know I have
been asking I said where does this
chicken so ask him again
[Music]
the middle of dinner service at Juniper
hillian and Chef Julian is drowning
under a flood of orders how am I
supposed to do everything back here
owner Roberts has finally decided to get
his hands dirty to try and help but he's
utterly incapable of communicating with
his Chef when he finishes it
send the [__] food it's always a
third dish not ready or a fourth dish
well it must be one or two moves behind
but unless you [__] ask how are you
supposed to [__] know
[Music]
table 23. I just told you one minute ago
I need Foie bra I know I have it right
behind me all right okay Julian yes
that's what you call communication it's
better communication that's what you
call communication Roberts there's a
difference between interrupting and no
communication and when you [__] put
those entrees up there you make sure
they go you've got to start stepping up
and [__] dictating a little bit
because this is just Madness I agree
Jesus Christ it was [__] ups
from start to finish and it was a
cluster [__] and Gordon saw that
Dreadful with an owner and Chef so
incapable of communicating with each
other it's no surprise the diners are
unhappy and they're not the only ones
while Robert nari are living the dream
their staff are living a nightmare
hopefully by gathering everyone in one
room okay I can get to the root of the
problem I've never seen a hotel and Inn
in such disarray there needs to be
structure and there isn't structure it's
just like a scramble it's a mess
there was no order in the kitchen nobody
took responsibility for any one thing no
one has been taught any standards in any
Department really it's like I'm racing
from thing to think nobody knows what
the other ones doing there's nobody here
that is in control willing to take
charge I did 40 [__] dinners by
myself tonight I could help you and
you've never asked I can cook the rack
of lamb excuse me bragging about it
excuse me one plate is nothing to brag
about excuse me excuse me I am the boss
you can't call yourself a boss if you
don't [__] pay them
I mean honestly do you think that's
normal Ari do you think that's the way
to look after your team every pay period
there is a problem with the checks every
pay period there's a problem with the
checks I don't know what the problem is
but I know it's the same two people and
you get to know about it first or you
have to go asking for your salary I
always ask for it that's absolutely
wrong and the reason is he's lying no no
no he's not lying I would rather have
them wait than write a check that's
going to bounce because I don't how
about telling him it's not gonna be
ready rather than having to ask like
some skivvy cap in hand please sir may I
get paid
anybody else have to wait yes how long
five days more Barbara I had to wait
five weeks he had to what I had to wait
five weeks before I got a paycheck five
weeks
guys you come in and you work your ass
off
the least these two guys can do is pay
your [__] salary on time I don't have
a secretary Gordon I'm sorry I'm trying
to communicate with Brides I'm trying to
send out things I have to have peaceful
time in order to do my work are you
always this the
I am not pathetic well when are you
gonna stand up and start showing some
respect for your team and start growing
a pair to sort of understand the measure
in I understand the mess we're in right
I'm fighting for the team you dug the
[__] hole yes and put them in it
so they're [__] they don't have to
work here
oh my I mean you know the bottom line is
how dare you no they don't have to work
here how dare you
how [__] dare you they don't have to
work here oh my God I I I can't
disrespectful disgusting man they don't
have to work here I don't think you
realize how [__] Lucky You Are
because it wasn't for one two three four
five six of them you'd be driving the RV
miles away from here
Robert definitely needs a reality check
it's life or death right now and I don't
think he actually realizes what kind of
Jeopardy this place is in it's not all
about you
you Robert it's only me in here excuse
me excuse me go on then you pomp as [__]
excuse me
don't talk to me what's wrong with this
I want to know don't speak to me well
I'm telling you you had out your ass and
start getting a little [__] real
you still haven't got it now this place
is sinking start paying a little bit
more attention to the guys on the ground
understand how hard it is out there
forget your [__] antique roadshow and
start from the bottom running this
business you're right there's no
structure it's fragmented the T needs a
leader they need a structure they need a
mentor I need some support
and all they get is nitpicked what kind
of motivation is that all I've heard
since I've been here you're just blaming
people well I'm blaming you for not
taking charge get [__] real
[Music]
yeah
so far my stay at Vermont Juniper Berlin
has been shocking yeah
[__] and the root of the problem is
beginning to show you don't get paid
I've seen with my own eyes how poorly
this place is run
but now I need to see what happens to
the bottom line when Robert and Ari used
Juniper Hill as their own private
playground and to tell me all their
friends I'm hoping estate manager Ryan
can help me a lot of the staff are
telling me their
um friends pop up from Manhattan and
come and spend weekends and sit drink
and be merry are these guys actually
paying
uh no Robert had a slew of friends come
and stay for free and eat for free for
weeks at a time and that's why they've
been losing money since I've been here
what do the colors mean help me
understand that green means they're paid
in full red means they have not paid
y'all I have 50 room nights that's
between November and December well just
to average there are two hundred dollars
a night with us it's like ten thousand
dollars in Revenue that's ten thousand
dollars
they're running it almost like a
clubhouse almost like they're trying to
buy friends and Robert Prides himself as
the superior business person Robert
walks around like he's the king and that
everybody hears a bunch of hicks this is
insane and this is like a private club
for him he's worked with the servers
before and accepted a portion of the
tips oh my God
[__] hell
taking their bloody tips and this guy is
mad I can't believe this he doesn't pay
them and then he takes their tips I
gotta talk to him
foreign how are we Barbara how are you
today good
I just have interest
Robert takes a percentage of the tips
it does
your tips as you take what we get he
gets the same as you yeah it's really
hard to keep track of the tips I at the
bookkeeping it doesn't it seems
inconsistent why is he touching the tips
he did the same thing for New Year's
they felt that because they needed to
cover part of the band that they took
the tips off I have a tip
that's why we don't make anything here
anona has no right to take the staff's
tips and with all the room and food
comps Robert is giving his friends it's
no wonder that Ian is struggling
the staff shouldn't be subsidizing the
end so Robert and his friends get to
live the high life for free it's
sickening I have to confront him and
figure out this nonsense
I just had a look round and I just
I am flabbergasted and I'm going to be
really Frank I'm going to try to stay so
calm but if I smell but yes that you
start going into denial I'm gonna let
rip again
I studied your reservations
last November December 49 rooms were
given out for free and on top of that
they ate they drank for nothing they're
not even tipping and I'm just what the
[__] are you doing tell me why I thought
I
needed to have somebody here rather than
having two other guests in the hotel all
by themselves to have more energy making
it worse not only do your friends not
leave tips but when people do tip the
staff you take a share on nights that I
work I did take time that is disgusting
[Music]
I think you are right to that I have
tried to work with my staff to teach
them that this is the way I want service
done it was so bad I take a percentage
of the tips based on the amount of work
that I do and who does the books on
those tips
um Ari but if I'm doing their job and I
can't get it across to them you're the
owner you're not the head bus boy you're
not the barman
you're the [__] owner what I was
saying wasn't getting through so the
psychology was that if I started to take
tips they would maybe pay attention to
that that is insane it's the worst
management model I've ever heard in my
entire life
do you honestly need a 70 year old
lady's tips
[Music]
so 15 20 rounds worth of complimentary
rooms in the food in a two-month period
I'm just it doesn't make sense I have to
tell you that the reason I did that was
because I thought that they would at
least tip my staff but they didn't tip
your staff
sorry to piss on your bonfire well then
I will call my friends and I will tell
them look what happened you haven't got
the [__] balls to call your friends
and ask them to leave a tip yes I do
call them then
and asked them I thought at least out of
generosity you would have left a couple
hundred dollars tip for the team hello
Dana yeah
it's Robert you stayed here recently
and
um I was under the impression that you
and Greg left a tip did you leave a tip
no no no but you said you were going to
send additional tips
I think my time's done here that was one
of the things that I was hoping you had
done
I left the money with you well wait a
minute there's others to call too Gordon
oh dear Gordon has left he thinks I'm
stealing my staff's tips unbelievable
[Music]
hey Ray it's Robert did you tip the
staff because they're telling people
that they haven't been tipped I left the
money with you oh so I need to do that
I I somehow lost that [__] idiot
Gordon left thinking I'm a liar
I feel as if I'm
I'm at the end of my row
I mean I'm gonna lose everything
I'm gonna have to start all over again
if this doesn't work and
I just don't seem like
I can't do it
no I can't do it
[Music]
I've just left Juniper Hill after
catching Robert in a lie about his staff
getting tips I was under the impression
that you and Greg left a tip did you
leave a tip
the guy is maddening and I don't know if
I've got it in me to help fix the place
I'm so pissed off with Robert right now
honestly I cannot stand anymore of these
bloody lies
this guy doesn't deserve the team that
is in his hotel he treats everyone so
badly when you're in your [__]
kitchen all day long and you're on the
internet instead of actually trying to
perfect a manual he doesn't even pay
them properly I had to wait five weeks
before I got a paycheck I work very long
days and I haven't been paid in three
weeks how can someone so rich not pay
the people he employs
that's something I simply won't stand
for
as angry as I am I feel I have to help
the staff get paid and I have an idea of
just how to do it I'm going to hire a
team of white Club movers to assemble
all of Robert's most valuable antiques
from the storage units the basement and
around the Inn I'm hoping when
confronted with all the money he's
wasted I can convince Robert to sell
some of his vast collection to pay his
staff
[Music]
if this is going to work and must stay
calm while I talk to Robert
um
I've come back not for you but for the
staff they deserve better
we're losing an average 15 to 20 000 a
month
we are short
but you have a serious hobby of sort of
an art collector and art dealer I mean
you could open a museum how many pieces
you have in this oh my God hundreds what
are we talking about everything
collectively
all those beautiful oil paintings the
expensive stuff at a suitable auction
um maybe three hundred thousand dollars
three hundred thousand dollars and that
would supplement you for the next 12
months 18 months yes that would
certainly get us through that would get
us through two years
um right there's something I want you to
see yeah I'd like you to come with me
please
that there's one thing we need right now
is an injection of funds
wow
Roberts no man alive needs this much
stuff walking in it was shocking now
antiques oil paintings silverware does
it not I mean frustrate you that we're
sat with all this
and yet we can't pay our staff properly
there's someone I'd like you to meet
she's the head Auctioneer at Bonhams in
Boston Amy good morning good morning
Gordon uh nice to see you Gordon great
to see you thank you so much for coming
um we're in the ship basically and this
stuff needs to go we need to raise as
much money as possible so what's the
best price we can get for all this stuff
[Music]
what you have here doesn't read as a
collection to me it's kind of an
accumulation a lot of copies of things
or if they are of the period that
they're supposed to be there's some
condition issues
um
I would say
about 25
000.
say that again 25 000.
25 000 dollars
all this all this
Amy's opinion on our our things was
shocking and I can't really believe that
and the painting the painting is a copy
and not a good one I'm afraid how much
does that work I can't imagine what
someone would pay for it it's really
very low value wow Robert I thought you
said it was expensive 18th century well
it's dated I dated 17. it is but it's
not actually of that period at all
sorry
did you know that was a copy I did not
know that that was a copy
lots of copies reproductions
reproductions we're hoping the ballpark
three to four hundred thousand twenty
five grand for everything
that won't even get us through the next
five weeks even all this amazing
silverware I put 100 handlers on
everything on this
dollars
first period this Sheffield yeah it's
complete what about this 175 bucks those
are baccarat candlesticks they just
don't bring very much at auction I'm
afraid is this the kind of collection
you'd be willing to sell at bottoms
would you take the whole lot no we
wouldn't well we would have to say no
we're floating as if we've got this
asset full of three or four hundred
thousand dollars worth of antiques we
haven't and we're distracted with the
bits of crap in here it was a wake-up
call thank you appreciate it thank you
it means that we don't have the backup
that we thought we had we've paid more
money for [__] storage than there
were than they're worth does that not
bring it home a little bit earlier that
you need to be an Innkeeper not a
part-time antiques dealer because you
fooled me you give me the tone I thought
wow this guy is uh he's got serious cash
to burn
but right now we're even further in this
[__] than I thought we were
so the pressure
intensifies yeah
you need to focus on fixing the business
because that's what's going to generate
sufficient funds to keep this place open
and I don't think you quite realize that
your staff
they're miserable
they don't like Aries barking excuse me
excuse me I am the boss are you bitching
when you're in your [__] kitchen all
day long and you're on the goddamn
internet instead of actually trying to
perfect a menu it's not a nice
atmosphere for the staff currently
and if they quit you're [__] they are
staff they're not pigs that live in the
[__] basement
think that's not the case and you're
that delusional and you're not prepared
to listen to anything I'm saying you're
[__]
sell the in sell this [__] in here and
give up
[Music]
I've just come back to try and save
Juniper Hill in and I thought I could
use some of the owners vast array of
antiques to get the cash flowing but
I've just discovered I would say about
twenty five thousand twenty five
thousand dollars all this all this
that I was wrong that won't even get us
through the next five weeks
with no assets the challenge to make
this place work is bigger than ever
tomorrow I have to start the process of
change
before I get stuck in there's one thing
I want to try
[Music]
it's bloody roasting
oh [__] my feet are freezing now
foreign
now it's time to see if I can get
through to Robert and Ari can I just
borrow you for two minutes I want to
show you something together I'd like to
come up to my uh room thank you if this
place is going to work as a business
Robert and Ari need to hear some home
truths about how their paying customers
really feel about their precious Inn
ladies and gentlemen good morning all
right thank you so much for uh popping
into my room
how was your stay last night well we
didn't know where to go when we walked
in so we walked around and around until
we found somebody to help us check in I
was like disorientated when I checked in
as well I mean there's no signs in terms
of reception desk or wow lounge or how
are the rooms how did space heaters oh
really yeah when I checked the room it
was like a sauna and he sounds
aggravated
raise your hands if you come back please
not like it is
there's someone I'd like to hear from
who hasn't said anything yet he is a
lead inspector of a Diamond collection
of hotel and Inns across America
in a nutshell very disappointed didn't
meet expectations from the moment I
walked in with no greeting no check-in
area I was totally lost and the bar is a
joke should not even be there folks it
looks as if it's set up for a wedding
the hospitality is nice but everything
else fails
how do you feel I don't want my guests
to have that experience you know our
goal is to please people that's why
we're in the in business and we've
obviously Fallen really short
um for me I think that's positive
feedback so I'm grateful entirely let me
tell you thank you all can I keep you
two here please thank you the guest
feedback has certainly been constructive
thank you and Robert's even using a word
I've never heard from him before we are
sorry but I'm shocked by Ari's response
to the guest complaints what's the
matter with you
why are you so angry with guests why are
you running an inn when you're so bitter
you look like you don't give a [__]
I'm not saying that I don't like to
guess but if you have ever been an
Innkeeper
it's 24 7. no one is more
touched by what these people said well
I would love this to be our private home
but I am and Ari does have a different
way of dealing with I see that based on
my experience
I would seriously request both you
actually sit down and reconsider whether
you should be in this business going
forward
[Music]
it's clear to me that Ari isn't cut out
for the hospitality business
and even though Robert now understands
how he's let down his guess he needs to
understand that he's also let down he's
starved and failed to recognize their
potential I've got a plan that will help
Robert to see what he's doing wrong and
how he can fix things in his kitchen
[Music]
I've asked Chef Julian to cook three
dishes from Robert's expensive old menu
and three new dishes of his very own
creation once he's finished we're going
to pretend I cook the new ones and see
what Robert says crucially Junior's
dishes are all ones that could be served
on a 29 menu half what Robert currently
charges look at that 74. 29 let's go
good luck
okay yes
I can't wait to see what Robert thinks
of Julian's affordable food when he
thinks I've cooked it I asked him to
cook a three-course meal yeah he cooked
his lamb his crab cake and the dessert
that's the 74 version I cook the other
meal I got hold of some chicken some
sprouts and I use the crab and I
butterscotch pudding with some
caramelized popcorn 29 that's what those
three courses are gonna cost yeah okay
Julian's three new dishes are fantastic
and fairly priced that would go a long
way towards bringing guests back through
the front door now the Robert thinks
I've cooked them I bet he loves them
talk to me excellent
fabulous and the Brussels sprouts are
really good too you've actually leafed
them and it's very pretty this is a much
better value
I've never heard you use that word value
and we could get two
price of one but we shouldn't do so my
menu or Julian's menu your menu my menu
I'm flattered but there's something I
need to tell you I didn't make any of
this Julian cooked everything
felt
very moment that I had done Julian a
disservice
Robert have you got something you'd like
to say to your Chef Julian I'm sorry
that I haven't given you the freedom to
do what you need to do
I guess I have to eat it and say that I
have restricted him from being who he
can be which is is really difficult and
I have to say that this is delicious
thank you
now that owner Roberts heard from the
guess very disappointed didn't meet
expectations and some of the kind of
affordable high quality food his Chef
can cook when given the chance excellent
fabulous I didn't make any of this
Julian cooked everything
I hope this is all started to sink in
with him
what how you feeling I'm feeling all
sorts of things I mean there's of course
fear
but surely hope too Yoshi's food was
amazing absolutely
it was an epiphany I feel
regretful that I have come across in the
way I have
and that I haven't exhibited to my staff
the leadership they needed and the
compassion that apparently I'm
I must be void of I think for you to
tell them how you're feeling what you're
going to commit to how important they
are for you I know that this place
wouldn't be here without them and I'm
wanting to do everything I can to show
them that we can make this work
I'm glad Robert's On A New Path I just
hope it's not too late for his staff to
learn to trust him again you are all
valuable to me and to Ari and to Juniper
Hill and I fear that we have not always
expressed that and
we want to show you that we are going to
make a difference
sorry for your paychecks being late
sorry for
taking part of the tips
sorry for not communicating
because that was the reality and one
that I'm not proud of that we're not
proud of
but one that we certainly can correct
and that's what we want to do
the business is short of cash flow I
thought there was a substantial
collection of three to four hundred
thousand dollars worth of assets
I mean why don't you explain exactly and
the things that were assembled here
um they said lucky if we got 25 000.
we all know us it is going to be
difficult and I think Robert has
realized
the bubbles burst and he understands
truth to where we are I think there's a
perception that we are these wealthy
magnets coming in and Lord of The Manor
sort of things that's not Who We Are
you know I knew there was some um bad
situations here but I stayed because I
want to be here and I want to help him
and I believe what he says and I'm very
proud of you Robert you're the man that
I've always known and loved it's he's
coming back I'm glad to see that you
know we're facing facts and that's the
only way we're going to get out of this
agreed thank you Ryan what'd you think
of what robbers just said I wanted to
stand up and clap I did too
I feel like I've been working for
somebody who can actually run a business
when I hear things like that that can
succeed
I've never seen Robert so serious this
is actually really a life-changing thing
for him and I feel like I want to be
part of the changes thank you thank you
thank you the truth is important it's
humbling to have to admit some of the
things that haven't gone right but at
the same time it's energizing to see
that people really do care for us and
care for Juniper Hill that is what's
going to make us successful I'm
impressed with the way Robert dealt with
his staff meeting I've got real hope
that he can make this place work but he
has another lesson to learn he thinks
people aren't spending money at Juniper
Hill because of the recession but I
think it's the snobbish atmosphere and
the high prices that have kept people
away I'm taking Robert to a fantastic
local Brewery to show him how a warm
welcome can translate into money in the
bank let's go and have a beer let's get
in with the locals trust me they won't
beat you up
laughs
you are like a fish out of water right
now honestly you're like a vegetarian in
the middle of a big steak tartare look
at you no no I love the people from our
region the Upper Valley is filled with
amazing people the Juniper Hill is not I
know we're local people wouldn't you
welcome this atmosphere oh yeah in your
stately house absolutely everyone is
what stand on there and tell them you
need them off we go if I could have your
attention please I'm Robert
I'm The Innkeeper Juniper Hill in we
just want to tell everybody we'd love to
have you all up at Juniper Hill Inn and
uh we need the help right now so if you
can come up and have dinner or just have
a drink and just say hi it would be
great thank you
Robert can always be that inviting to
the locals he surely has it in him to be
the leader of the Inn remember the last
time you brought Ari here for beer we
haven't been here probably in six months
how was he after he spoke to the team
like that you know the the interesting
thing with Ari is his exterior is
finished you know he's very Stern
but he feels deeply you can't express it
though can he can't he's emotionally
constipated I think he gave up that
can't come across to the staff that
can't come across the customer so you
you've got to almost isolate yourself
from that but he's getting through it
but he's not going to be the face he's
not going to be the no he's not but he
can provide a phenomenal amount of
support behind the scenes cheers to that
it's been a tough week here at Juniper
Hill Inn and owner Roberts pompous ways
have been maddening I don't have a
secretary Gordon I'm sorry are you
always this pathetic
but he's finally come off his pedestal
to get on the same level as his team you
are all valuable to Juniper Hill and we
want to show you that we are going to
make a difference
overnight my team has been working on a
remarkable transformation and with
relaunch upon us it's a chance for a
fresh start for everyone good morning
good morning
let me introduce you to the new
Juniper Hill Inn it's no longer a
hangout for the super rich or your mates
getting freebies yeah it's now a nice
warm and very welcoming Country Inn and
trust me everyone is welcome whether
you're driving up here in a Mercedes or
even a pickup truck
you ready yes let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go
please come in
come through the Great Hall is a
beautiful room but it was hidden by vast
amounts of furniture oh my goodness look
at this my team have edited the
collection and created a feeling of
comfort and space when I walked in at
the Great Hall it felt like a different
room Gordon put together this amazing
place it feels comfortable and warm you
have a spacious gracious warm reception
room look at it
gone is That Hideous makeshift bar
gone yes nowhere to go because they have
proper signs
you ready to see the dining room yeah
come through
oh it's warm and welcoming oh I love
this no longer feels like your
grandmother's parlor it really is a
dining room it's what you expect from
the Country Inn you know it has an
identity a lot of those hideous sofas
that nobody can sit and eat dinner with
all right what do you think very nice
you like it very open excellent
I'm showing my bedroom okay please
everybody else can come too please
you ready we're ready here you go
do you know what's wrong with this room
nothing
you don't need to do anything to them
the only thing wrong was a smelling room
one and a plumber is taking care of that
the guest rooms are the absolute
highlights of your Inn that meant
something because it meant we were on
the right track we just needed a better
directions now the key to filling this
is to charge sensible prices
I would rather have the room sold at a
cheaper price and have an 85 percent
occupancy rate across the year and the
price is down fill it let them enjoy
this quality
stunning bedrooms didn't need changing
but there's one room that did need a
significant overhaul in order to bring
in much needed cash flow now there's one
more little thing I want to show
downstairs okay you ready I'm ready
let's go come with me
okay
we need to attract the local community
I'd like to welcome you to the Blue Bar
um
Ari aren't you thrilled the best new
local bar in Windsor fantastic this is
so crazy block it and see the people
sitting there and the games on the
tables and the Beautiful drinks it was
very emotional I loved it
the blue bar is exactly what the town of
Windsor Vermont and Juniper Hill in need
I'm hoping it'll be popular especially
on a day like today when the in-house is
first ever Sunday lunch service the
staff are all getting ready for the
arrival of their lunch guests five six
seven eight so you got four tables each
but why everybody else is busy Ari seems
lost and needs reminding of his role
here at the Inn I'm here
right
had to go the other way are you in are
you out are you doing the checks what
are you doing I was checking in people
but I thought that was the greatest show
I thought you were checking in people
you want to check them in and take them
up that'll be great which makes these
are kind just two seconds I'm so sorry
would you continue that of course
I thought you're gonna leave the front
although you're going to be the back of
the house number one things that Robert
asked me to to check in people uh
because he had to uh take people to the
dining room
we have a saying in England yes too many
chefs spoil the broth I'm not a natural
Innkeeper
[Music]
just explain to Robert that you're gonna
support him from behind the scenes
please sure please I'm gonna do that I
think Ari has finally got the picture
and understands that he needs to play to
his Trends I really hope that things can
continue to improve now foreign
it's a place where we eat come on Sophie
come on come come that's not for you
come on come on come on come on honey
excuse me come on come on I take care of
the dog okay excuse me the dog shouldn't
be in the bar he's on the seats eating
the food really I am the boss okay don't
ever talk to me that way again excuse me
don't ever and I mean it
I'll be in my room and I don't need to
be yelled at
[Music]
I'm coming towards the end of my stay at
Vermont's Juniper Hill Inn and I thought
we'd turn the corner but as the end's
first ever Sunday lunch service
approaches assistant Inky Persona has
gone missing where's our
gone I haven't seen Sarah in about a
half an hour she okay
tell Noah you don't know okay just
asking
a Sarah gone home
no the team can't afford to be a man
down I've got to find her
what is it it's me Sarah's Gordon oh hi
Gordon you okay oh no
hold on a second
Danny I thought you joining us for lunch
oh thanks I'm not going to
you want to come here yeah you look
terrible what's the matter oh I'm just
really upset how do we get upset you're
with us half an hour ago
customers are in the bar I know when the
first level's just arrived I just expect
you to be there in terms of you're part
of this team I know but I'm sick of
being yelled at by Ari I'm sick of it
Gordon when did you yell at you just a
few minutes ago because I asked him to
take the dog out of the dining room
naturally it's his dog and it's sitting
on the bar furniture please come back
down oh buck up and come down nobody's
ever seen me break down in tears in this
end it's never happened before just come
back downstairs okay please okay yeah I
want to help I don't want to see you
upset and the girls need you down there
they do and I'm just I'm just really mad
at them no well let me go and have a
word with Ari this is ridiculous get
yourself ready places full of locals and
they'd love to see you too okay please
at Smiley yes yes yes I'll bounce back
I'm not sure why Ari is snapping at his
staff but it just proves my gut was
right about his place being behind the
scenes all right yes
I've just found Sarah upstairs and
floods of Tears everything okay no we
had a little running because we both
have very strong people
he snapped at me and I snapped back do
you think the dog should be running
around in the bar no no I went there I
guess I said was she right or wrong
would it be appropriate for you to
apologize to her did you feel that
you're responsible from behind the
scenes is there any way we could just
for this first Sunday lunch sure try to
keep the team together okay
I think Ari's heart is in the right
place but his tone is all wrong for an
Innkeeper he needs to be the power
behind the throne
I'm sure this is going to be one of the
busiest days yet at Juniper Hill Inn and
I need to remind Chef Julian to make
good use of his sous chef Nida if he's
gonna have any chance of being
successful Junior's proves Robert and I
that he has the talent and the potential
in the kitchen now he just needs the
help to execute I know you're adamant
the fact that you're going to work on
your own but you're not a one-man band
yeah yeah sure encourage entice
over the stove
the local community have responded to
Robert's invitation and there's a great
atmosphere as people turn up to check
out the bar and Sample the new menu I
put together with Chef Julian Tara nice
to see you welcome to Juniper Hill hi
iron here nice to see you as well as new
arrivals the Inn has a return guest
hotel inspector Steve Talon his first
visit was a disaster very disappointed
didn't meet expectations from the moment
I walked in with no greeting I was
totally lost this is Robert and his
team's chance to prove to Steve that
they've learned the lesson I hope this
time
how are you Mr Talon nice to see you
nice to you welcome so this is our new
menu
okay let's go next coming up next we
have one Trout the key to this place
running smoothly is communication among
the entire staff but Chef Julian still
doesn't seem to get that
how long for the first flat ironing
play talks Anita I don't care what it's
about the [__] weather I don't care
but talk to her okay
come on you gotta talk
I said come on
and put things on a plate for you just
refusing to talk to her and it's been so
[__] painful now
I simplified the menu in order to get it
so much easier for you know that yeah
sure and the menu was designed for you
to open up and talk okay yeah sure look
at me position your mind out and all you
do is one plate Focus next plane focus
and I just want you to open up a little
bit she's there to help thank you
you know what let me do this
just help with the Skillets help with
the skillet [__] it now Julian yes come
here
what's the matter with you you just shut
down on me now do you want to give me
your jacket I'll do it for you no Chef
it's not difficult can you do this
open up come on just shut down
[Music]
with Robert working well with the team
okay thank you so much and how are you
staying out the way the bar is bustling
how are you welcome
can I get you to drink but Chef Junior
needs to raise his game and start
communicating if we're going to make
today a success you've just shut down on
me open up please get it together let's
go
[Music]
you're about four minutes to that table
I'm afraid I do one place they're good
all right so then you get with the lamb
shank then you get some lamb glaze which
is right here Julian nice much better
look at me much better yeah sure good
how is everybody out there
the locals are definitely noticing a
change here it was wonderful very good I
was very surprised
time to see if the hotel inspector has
two noises
see you again good to see you too
recognize a few changes in some ways I
didn't recognize it at all right what
the interest on in terms of the total
openness
for the signs everywhere when you walked
in with the warmth oh it's grave now I
feel it has that time and collection
feel good
enjoy lunch appreciate it pork's amazing
okay thank you there's a great Buzz at
the end sir
yes I hope that's not all about to
change I'm really busy
I'm sorry
this food is affordably priced it's
really really tasty and it's nice to
know a nice place to send people to get
a drink and relax and everything
hard in the area that's great Robert and
I's communication has improved by Leaps
and Bounds since I've been at the Inn
but actions speak louder than words and
I think Robert is starting to understand
that I just wanted to tell you that I
really appreciate all the extra effort
you're given not just this week but
the entire time you've been here and
this is your paycheck literally because
I know you need it we wish we had more
we put a hundred dollars extra in there
for you just so you have
a little bit extra because we really do
appreciate you Ryan
you and I are going to bring this back
and are you going to join us
I haven't been that emotionally moved in
a long time I
I feel like it's all been worth it now I
just I feel like it's appreciated
what a week I think this business is on
the road to recovery and Robert
Andy's team with Ari in the background
can really make this place work because
once the locals invest in this place
word it's gonna spend Big Time wow
beautiful
it's time for me to say my goodbyes but
with a crowd enjoying themselves in the
bar and loving the Great Value in the
dining room is a host to leave really
good this is a nice company we're
sharing the lamb shakes for them okay
you're welcome nice
uh right finally you think we've got
this under control yes yes yes and
you're opening up yes yes don't stop
talking yeah communicate good job thank
you Chef he might have beat a few people
down but then he brought a few people
right back up and that was necessary I'm
just glad he didn't smack me with a
spatula
Ari I've come to say goodbye I was uh
you're writing paychecks yes good the
place it's a business absolutely look
after yourself look after Robert and
support him in all the right places
thank you best wishes we are very
grateful for him that he has passion for
us
because it's not easy to
restructure molded Minds look after
yourself yes look after yourself how are
you feeling I'm feeling great and it
seems like you've got this under control
I'm going to keep it under control well
to start doing the job the bar is
functioning the dining room is
functioning kitchen's functioning that's
good that's beautiful oh he's in the RV
and there are people and they seem to be
having a good time you're on the track
now we're on track I have a little
present for you stay there having Gordon
come to Juniper Hill has meant a lot to
us it was harder than hell but
ultimately I know it's going to do great
things for our staff and for our town
this is something that money cannot buy
but this week you've earned it now the
most important thing please keep it up
this is your side to be part of the
amazing setup the Diamond collection
thank you you deserve us thank you well
done thank you safe journey he really
did awaken me put a fire in me and I
want him to come back and say
he really did it that's our goal take
care bye-bye
have a beautiful day
the storage units are still there
oh it was Robert I'd like Ari in one of
them
[Music]